So you I I'm glad that we're actually
here. Ironically, you you went to
Genesis 1:26, which was going to be a
part of my next question, so I I might
as well ask it now. It's the way that I
perceive it, right? So in the New
Testament, when they say the Father, the
Son, and the Holy Spirit, the way that I
interpreted that was back in when they
said, uh, then God said, "Let us make
man in our image." Yes. According to our
likeness, right? and let them rule over
the fish of the sea and over the birds
of the sky and over the cattle and over
the earth. So the way I perceive our in
Genesis 1:26 and at the same time when I
when I hear them say the father, the son
and the holy spirit. So am I under the
right understanding of there was no
angels or prophets at that exact time in
126. So just like in us humans we have
our physical form, our spiritual form
and our soul, right? Three different
things that create one being.
>> Yes.
>> So I mean it all has such correlation
the old and the new.
>> I'm going to expound it your
understanding. It's not that it refers
to you as a body and a soul because
you're still one person whereas the
father his word and spirit they're not
the same self. Meaning because they're
distinct, they actually interact with
one another, love one another, have
fellowship. That's why it says, "Let
us," that means he's speaking to others
who are conscious, right?
>> Yeah.
>> He's not talking to himself. But at this
stage when God created man, there were
angels. That's why the rabbis say God
was speaking to the angels. But I'm
going to address that. I'm going to get
that point by point. We're going to go
Genesis 1 and show you how deep it is.
But again, another example just before I
get to there. This is Tarum Jerusalem,
Genesis 3. And the word of the Lord God
said, "Behold, Adam whom I have created
is soul in my world as I am soul in the
heavens above."
So, are you noticing these are Jewish
paraphrases, not Christian that are
recognizing that in places where God
speaks or God appears, it's actually the
word of God. The word of God is saying,
"I created Adam. The word of God created
man in his image." So, now these Jews
are not Christians. They're not
influenced by the New Testament, but
they can see from the reading of the
scriptures
that God is multi-personal and complex.
>> Yeah.
>> And what the New Testament does, it
simply picks up on that and says, "Yes,
he is." And this word who's not the
father that the Jews recognize is a
living
person who speaks, can be spoken to, who
creates, who punishes, who forgives,
does things what God does. That's the
word who became the man Jesus. Now, as
far as Genesis 1 is concerned, I'm going
to go through it systematically with
you.
We're going to go right here.
What people don't catch, unless you can
read the Hebrew, and you don't need to
read the Hebrew, you have lexicans. But
again, the key here is following how man
mimics God to a limited, finite,
temporal
sense. What do I mean? God is not
physical. So, he doesn't have a body by
nature. He's not embodied. God is not
bound to space and place. Man is. So,
when we say man resembles God, we're not
saying he's identical to God. That's
impossible. Nothing's identical to God.
But he more closely resembles God than
any creature. Because God wanted man to
resemble him more so than anything else.
This is why if you read the narrative
carefully, just read the narrative.
Whenever God creates, he says, "Let
there be. Let there be. Let there be."
But then when it comes to man, he
changes the way he creates man. Let us
make man in our image. Right?
>> Changes his whole vocabulary. when you
get a moment. I'm going to change the
translation because I want to give you
one that's more literal. Right. Let me
go here.
If you read up until that point, God
said, "Let there be light." He didn't
say, "Let us make light." See, God said,
"Let there be light." Right? God said,
"Let notice every time he's training, he
doesn't say, "Let us do this. Let there
be." Boom. And there was. Yet when it
comes to man, he changes his vocabulary.
Follow it. And this is something that
troubled the rabbis in the tom. You'll
see the rabbis were trouble with it. If
I say, "Yeah, he's talking to angels."
Can't be. Because angels, even the
rabbis will admit angels had no role to
play in creating anything. They were
passive observers. But to get away from
the fact that God is speaking to others
who are personally involved in actually
creating they have no he's just
addressing themly council without
necessarily getting them involved. Well
hold on
let's read. God said let us make man now
the Hebrews Adam that'll be significant
a little later in our image according to
our likeness. Now pay attention to how
the pronouns change. And let them rule.
Who's them?
It's only Adam right now.
>> But Adam is a them. It's plural.
>> Why?
>> I don't know.
>> Because if you read it, Adam is not one
person. I'm going to prove it to you.
Let them rule over the fish of the sea
and over the birds and over the wild
animals, over all the earth, and over
everything that creeps and moves on the
earth. Does God create the man? And the
Hebrew is Adam. I'll show it to you in
his image. In the image of God, he
created him. He created them male and
female. That's the key. The one Adam,
the hymn is male and female. It's the
them.
Now, I'm going to show you why it's
plural. Well, I'm going to see. Because
God is influent wise. He's already
showing you in the creation of Adam
being a plural. One Adam, but more than
one person of the same flesh, different
gender. He reflects the fact the one God
is more than one person of the same
nature. I'm going to show it to you
systematically.
Now, watch here.
One more time, it says, "Let us make
man." And I'm going to show you that the
Hebrew says Adam in a minute. In our
image, according to our likeness, let
them. So the Adam is a them together.
God created the man Adam in his image.
In the image of God, he created him. So
Adam is a him. He created them male and
female. So the him is a them. The Adam
is male and female. And that's why right
here, Genesis 5:es 1 and 2, I want you
to watch this. This is the book of the
generations of Adam. On the day that God
created Adam, he made him, notice, Adam
is a him.
>> Yeah.
>> In the likeness of God. But then here is
the shocker. He created them male and
female. And blessed them and called
their name Adam.
Adam is not one person.
Do you see it?
>> I see it.
>> It's not one person. Even though Adam is
a him,
he's not one person. This one Adam is
multi-personal. Adam is a them. Male and
female, two different genders, two
distinct physical beings, two different
physical bodies, but together are the
one Adam.
Now, how does this reflect God? I'm
going to show you systematically.
Right?
So in creating man plural, God was
showing that the creator is plural. Like
Adam is more than one person. Two
different genders, two different
physical beings, two different physical
bodies, but have the same nature and
therefore they're one atom. The God who
made them is also
more than one person, distinct persons
that have the same nature. And because
they have the same nature, they're one
God, but not one person.
So what makes male and female the one
atom right here?
So the Lord God
formed from the earth every wild animal
and every bird of the sky and brought
them to the man to see what he would
call them. Now at this time there is no
Eve. But now watch though. For whatever
the man named the living creature, so
was its name. Therefore, the man gave
names to all cattle, and to the birds of
the sky, and to every wild animal, but
Adam found no perfect mate for himself.
Therefore, the Lord God caused a heavy
sleep to fall upon the man, and he
slept, and he took one of his ribs, and
the Hebrew can also mean side, closed up
the flesh in its place, and with the
side or rib which the Lord God had taken
from the mammon, he made a woman. Now
the woman comes, but where did she come
from? Did she come from the dust?
>> No. Adam's rib.
>> That means in a sense she was always an
atom, right?
>> Yeah. That's why he's referring to them
as them.
>> And that's why she's called a woman
because you notice the part woman,
there's the word man in there, right?
>> Yep.
>> And that's why she's called woman
because you're going to see. And he
brought her to the man. Then the man
said, "This now is bone of my bones.
She's my bones. She's made of my bones.
She's my flesh. She was taken from my
flesh. And because she's my flesh and
she's my bones, she shall be called
woman because she was taken out of the
man. Woman means from the womb of man.
That's why in a woman you have man in it
because to show that she originates from
man. Now in the Hebrew it says she'll be
called isha because she came from ish.
In Hebrew the word ish means male or
husband. Isha means female or wife. So
in the Hebrew if you're looking I'll
show it to you. says she will be called
Isha because she came out of ish. But
the key here is therefore man shall
leave his father and his mother and
shall cling to his wife. They shall be
one flesh. Now what's beautiful about
the word one
that's the same word used in the shama
shama is elohu
they are bas.
So when God says, "Let us make man in
our image." Now you see the connection.
The one man,
the one flesh,
is more than one person. Two different
physical bodies, two different physical
genders, two different different
physical persons. But because they have
the same nature, they are still one
atom. So the God who created Adam
plural, he himself is plural. That's why
he says, "Let us because this one God is
more than one person."
Not the same person, but because of the
same nature, they're the same God.
That's the key. Not that you're body and
soul. No, that Adam is male and female.
And together, they're the one flesh, the
one Adam. So, notice they're not two
flesh. They're one. But we know that
doesn't mean that two distinct flesh
bodies don't exist. Eve has her own
flesh and she has her own unique
characteristics and different body
parts. Man has his own flesh and his own
body parts, which is why, you know,
that's a man, not a woman. But because
one originates from the other, and
together they complete each other, even
though they're two, you consider them
one.
That's the teaching of the Trinity.
>> Though God the Father and his word
begotten of him and his eternal spirit,
they're not the same self. That's why
they can talk to one another, relate to
one another, have communion with one
another, and love one another because
their origin is one, their nature is
one. It's one God, not three gods.
>> Thanks for clearing that. Actually makes
a lot more sense.
>> You see, so you're catching why Adam is
still one atom. Because the flesh is
one. She's of Adam's flesh. And because
together they complete each other, it's
in that union that they are one. Because
God says when the male is by himself,
that's not good.
It's not good when he's by himself. That
means it's in the union of the two that
Adam is complete.
Here it is.
So if God is telling you solitariness
is not good,
being by yourself, a single person is
not good. You're telling me then God is
a singular person. When he says that's
not a good thing to be a singular
person, solitary here it is also the
Lord God said is not good that the man
should be alone. I will make a perfect
mate for him. This is the only time in
the creation that God said something is
not good. Every time he created
something good, it's good, good, good.
But when he saw the male by himself,
that is not good.
So if God is telling you solitariness,
singleness, being a singular person by
yourself is not good. You're telling me
God the ground of all exist existence
and the ground of all goodness who's
perfectly good is a solitary person. No,
he's not.